this daily outing around their toronto
neighborhood might become the norm for
sarah jackson and her family over the
next couple of weeks as her kids return
to online learning it's a lot to
figure out time and time again omicron's
wildfire increase in cases has pushed
ontario and quebec to return to remote
schooling for a couple weeks at least
while bc and alberta have pushed back
post-holiday start dates i certainly
recognize it's very very difficult for
parents and for students to manage that
kind of thing
but
we're kind of in a crisis mode right now
so i think we need to pull out all the
stops some public health experts agree
that means pulling kids out of class
others worry advice to avoid this
scenario again has fallen on deaf ears
over the last year
take enhancing ventilation and
filtration
what i feel very confident in saying is
that we're probably underpowered in a
lot of classrooms six air changes every
60 minutes is best and a single hepa
filter won't cut it many schools don't
have the funding to do major upgrades
and if they do it can take time in the
short term there's masking experts say
it's time to ditch the cotton face cover
and upgrade to a surgical mask at the
very least and while some are even
advocating for n95s in schools there's
debate among infectious disease
specialists it's it's a little bit more
difficult to sort of imply that kind of
reach out to the community and it's
really important to understand n95 mass
are much more expensive in ontario the
association advocating for its english
language public schools wants the
province to pick up the tab and is also
hoping to see the covet 19 vaccine
become mandatory for all students over
age five
across canada just over one percent of
kids five to 11 have received their
double dose so far but we still do have
a lot of families that haven't yet made
the decision to get their child
vaccinated and that's going to set us
back a little bit
until there's an increase in uptake
public health experts are again calling
for smaller class sizes
jackson's partner sammy agrees but isn't
hopeful some of this stuff like you
can't change overnight meantime the most
obvious piece of advice to keep kids
coveted free falls on parents like him
in an omicron era at the first sign of
sniffles
stay home jamie morrocker global news
toronto